Lisbakken: Hey there.
My name's Ben Lisbakken
and I'm an engineer
here at Google.
I'm gonna be giving a session
at Google I/O
called Fun Hacks
and Cool JavaScript.
It's about just that
as it pertains
to the AJAX API Playground,
a creation of mine.
The Playground is a place
where you can go
and be educated on Google's
JavaScript APIs.
It has over 190 samples
that you can select from,
see the code for,
and see what they output.
Then if you want
you can edit the code,
you can customize it to do
exactly what you want it to do,
then you can run it again
on the same page.
You can save your code.
You can also export it
to a sticky URL
where you can share it with
your friends.
But talking about just
the Playground
isn't quite enough.
What I'd really like to do
is delve into how
I created the Playground.
Specifically, I think
that web developers out there
know JavaScript, but they don't
know JavaScript well enough
because there's a lot
of advanced techniques
that you--that can be used
in JavaScript.
So I'd like to spend
some time teaching
a little bit more advanced
JavaScript.
Then I'd like to talk
about some of the fun hacks
that went into the Playground.
For instance, I found out
how I could run code
on Google.com and have this be
arbitrary JavaScript
that you developers
were creating
but not have any security issues
with you guys trying
to hack Google.
Also what I'll do is show
how I created break points
for JavaScript
written in JavaScript,
which was definitely
a fun hack.
Then if there's time,
I'd like to talk about
the XSRF vulnerability,
which is a very serious
and common vulnerability
for web applications.
And after that if there's time,
I'd love to talk about
web performance
because front end web
performance is very important.
You could increase the traffic
to your site
by having a performance site
and it's very easy to increase
the performance.
So if you guys have time,
come on down and stop by
my session.
I'd love to have you
and teach you guys
some cool JavaScript
and other front end
fun stuff.
All right, thank you.